George Floyd's hometown of Houston is
preparing for what's expected to be a
big March day today in his honor as the
city prepares for the March the police
chief is being credited with helping
keep days of protests their peaceful
Janet shamlian is in Houston with that
part is part of the story Janet what is
this chief doing he always gets a lot of
attention he is a rock star for a lot of
people that is true Gale good morning to
you so the chief art acevedo has been a
very visible presence here over the past
week everything from speaking at
churches to marching right alongside
those protesters perhaps the city's
biggest gathering will happen here this
afternoon starting in this downtown Park
and led by the family of George Floyd
[Applause]
Houston
George Floyd's home town has seen loud
and raucous protests over the last week
and more than 100 arrests but they
haven't been the large riots and looting
plaguing other US cities it's a city
where we have worked really diligently
through relational policing to build
relationships with this community and
we've got a lot of emotional capital
that we've built up that we're now using
to keep our city safe
many believe it's largely due to the
presence of Houston police chief art
acevedo himself appearing in almost
every protest over the past week sharing
the community's pain over the city with
blacks and whites and browns and legal
and illegal
I'll get together because we judge each
other by the content of our art he has
walked the city streets alongside
demonstrators prayed with them at church
and expressed anger at the few who came
to cause trouble
[Music]
appointed by the city's black mayor
Sylvester Turner acevedo changed his
Twitter profile picture to a drawing of
George Floyd he says the goal of today's
rally is to keep the focus on Floyd I
think the wall honor him by not letting
people hijack what we should be focusing
on and that is acting in a manner that
brings change not in a manner that will
change the conversation from police
misconduct and criminality to the thugs
and and and all the people burning stuff
that's not what needs to happen in our
city across the country in amid the
chaos similar efforts of unity law
enforcement in Washington DC taking a
knee in front of the Trump Hotel and
Chicago's Police Superintendent David
Brown responding to peaceful protesters
chanting say his name but today publicly
I want to say his name as a police
leader of the second largest Police
Department in the country mr. joy
Floyd we grieve with you and your family
they are important gestures Acevedo says
but only a start we can't lose sight of
the fact that when bad policing happens
it disproportionately impacts community
of color communities of color and poor
communities including white poor
community so we need to take a step back
and speak the truth everybody knows the
truth when they see it we just have to
open our eyes and the chief says he
expects a large peaceful event here
today meanwhile funeral arrangements
have been announced for George Floyd a
public viewing in the Houston area next
Monday followed by his funeral on
Tuesday Gayle yeah some tough times to
come but let me just say something about
chief art acevedo Janet I've been
watching him for years
he never shied away from hard truths he
walks the walk and talks to talk and
he's always accountable for what happens
in his city and he's such a great
cheerleader too yes
I believe it will be peaceful in Houston
Thank You Janet very much